oh my god i was on your instagram and i
saw the the poop in the eardrum oh yeah
yeah how was your ear by the way
i i i went to the to the doctor for my
two week follow-up and he said that the
hole in my eardrum closed
on its own
i'm almost completely magnified
like there's yeah i don't think there's
poop inside now
okay that's good
they cleaned it out well
yeah well that was the thing i don't
think i don't think the poop actually
broke my eardrum i think that it was
when i went in to get it flushed out the
the flushing of the water didn't
puncture your eardrum it was probably
the 1800 psi
air gun to your side of your face that
broke your eardrum out maybe i'm going
to go with scott yeah
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude